tes coups de blues des coups de fil tour
commencera au printemps elle dit que la
musique l'a sauvée alors qu'elle n'était
encore qu'une adolescente et mis 19 ans
est aujourd'hui une chanteuse
indépendante qui a su se faire connaître
à la voix douce et touchante et au
parcours incroyable mars 1998
emilie de son vrai prénom n'est atteinte
d'une maladie génétique rare s'empaler
et malentendantes une maladie presque
invisible jusqu'à ses 14 ans est alors
une enfant comme les autres qui aiment
sourire aux caractères bien prononcé
tout bascule à l'adolescence l'âge où
les jeunes adultes se chercher les mots
deviennent blessant quand j'étais plus
jeune on primaires c'était des petits
nous insultent ou d'enfants ou des
jardins contre ce type avec mais c'était
pas encore violent comme les adolescents
après ce qui a été le plus violent pour
moi ça a été une crachats mais je suis
cracher dessus
à mon arrivée au collège et ça c'est
quelque chose que je n'oublierai jamais
jugé moquée et me traverse alors des
années compliquer la vie de famille s'en
trouve parfois chamboulé heureusement
pour elle l'amour des plus proches
résisté notamment les amitiés
là c'est une amie d'enfance qui j'étais
en primaire bailliage stéphanie qui est
là aussi et là y'a mélanie c'est ma
meilleure amie
c'est des amis qui ont été là vraiment
dans les pyrénées comme dans les
meilleures années n'ont jamais lâché
n'ont jamais juger donc pour moi c'est
comme une famille d'ailleurs c'est une
seule photo que j'ai dans ma chance et
je pense que c'est important de garder
ça actuellement et à côté d'elle ses
meilleurs amis le sont aussi dans sa
carrière de chanteuse la musique est un
destin qui amy a su se forger à 17 ans
presque tout seul dans sa chambre
des vidéos postées sur internet la
rencontre avec l'auteur boris bergman et
un premier single enregistré en 2016
[Musique]
nous sert de
besoin de t'oublier
bouya j'ai ma mi mai
commencée depuis le succès d'amy se
confirme dix mille fans sur facebook et
instagram la jeune bachelière souhaite à
travers son parcours porter un message
d'espoir oui c'est dur chez c'est dur -
vous êtes pas enfin vous êtes pas moins
qu'un doute en fait il n'y a personne au
dessus il ya personne dessous on est
tous capables on a tous des capacités et
c'est pas parce qu'on est malade qu'on a
pu ses capacités mais le problème des
gens c'est que les jambons vous font
croire ça et à force à court de vous y
croyez au fait et c'est ça c'est ça il
faut pas tomber dans le piège en
septembre et mis débutera un bts en
alternance elle sortira bientôt
également un premier harper symbole d'un
équilibre retrouvé qu'elle souhaite
partager statue de cire
je fonce en tout
poirier